I'M OPRAH AND I LOVE YOU.
JESSE: WELCOME TO "WATTERS'
WORLD."
I'M CENTIMETRES.
THE JURY REACHED A VERDICT.
>> THE FIRST COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION WE THE YURI FIND THE
-- THE JURYFIND THE DEFENDANT E
RITTENHOUSE NOT GUILTY.
THE THIRD COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION, UNNORTHERN MALE, WE
FIND THE DEFENDANT KYLE
RITTENHOUSE NOT GUILTY.
AS TO THE FIFTH COUNT OF THE
INFORMATION, GAIGE GROSSKREUTZ,
WE THE YURI FIND THE DEFENDANT
NOT GUILTY.
JESSE: NOT GUILTY ON ALL
CHARGES.
JUSTICE WAS SERVED.
OUR SYSTEM WORKS.
THE JURY WAS UNDER INTENSE
PRESSURE BY PROTESTERS AND THE
MEDIA TO DELIVER A GUILTY
VERDICT.
THE JURORS WERE TALKED BY THE
PRESS.
BUT THEY WERE ABLE TO SEE PAST
THE RECKLESS.
THE JURY BUCKED THE MOB.
THEY LISTENED TO THE TESTIMONY.
WATCHED THE VIDEOS FROM THAT
NIGHT AND HEARD FROM THE
DEFENDANT THEMSELVES.
HERE IS WHAT THE DEFENSE HAD TO
SAY AFTER THE VERDICT.
I WISH NOBODY DIED.
I WISH I NEVER MET KYLE
RITTENHOUSE.
I DON'T MEAN BECAUSE HE'S A BAD
CLIENTS.
BUT THEN THIS WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED.
>> JUSTICE IS DONE WHEN THE
TRUTH IS REACHED.
I DON'T KNOW IT'S SET UP LIKE
THAT.
THIS CASE BECAME ABOUT WINNING.
JESSE: .
REMEMBER THIS IS THE SAME MEDIA
THAT WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE THEY
WERE MOSTLY PEACEFUL PROTESTS AS
THE FIRE WAS BLAZING BEHIND
THEM.
DID THEY STOP?
NO.
THE PRESS POLLUTED THE JURY
POOL, SLANDERED THE DEFENDANT
AND ATTACKED THE JUDGE.
THIS VERDICT REPRESENTED A
MASSIVE LOSS FOR THE CORPORATE
MEDIA.
THE RACIAL VIGILANTE STORY LINE.
ALL OF THOSE FOLDED.
DID THEY LEARN THEIR LESSON?
AFTER THE VERDICT POLITICIANS
FANNED THE RACE FAN.
CORI BUSH TWEETING THIS.
THE JUDGE, THE JURY, THE
DEFENDANT, IT'S WHITE SUPREMACY
IN ACTION.
THE SYSTEM ISN'T BUILT TO HOLD
WHITE SUPREMACISTS ACCOUNTABLE.
IT'S WHY BLACKS AND BROWNS ARE
PUT IN CAGES WHILE WHITES ROAM
FREE.
EVEN THE DISGRACED ATHLETE COLIN
KAEPERNICK TWEETED WE JUST
WITNESSED A SYSTEM BUILT ON
WHITE SUPREMACY VALIDATING THE
ATTACK OF A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
IT SHOWS THE NEED TO ABOLISH OUR
SYSTEM.
WHITE SUPREMACY CANNOT BE
REFORMED.
REMEMBER WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
CALLED RITTENHOUSE A WHITE
SUPREMACIST?
DOES HE STAND BY THAT STATEMENT?
>> DO YOU STAND BY YOUR PAST
COMMENT WHEN YOU TWEETED ABOUT
WHITE SUPREMACY?
>> I STAND BY WHAT THE JURY
CONCLUDED.
THE JURY SYSTEM WORKS AND WE
HAVE TO ABIDE BY IT.
JESSE: LATER PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
PUPPET MASTERS CLEANED UP THE
STATEMENT SAYING HE WAS ANGRY
ABOUT THE VERDICT.
THE MEDIA LOST.
CORRUPT PROSECUTORS LOST.
DEFUND THE POLICE LOST.
AND SELF-DEFENSE